so
[Music]
[Applause]
happy nfl sunday everybody you just
tapped into the squad ride live in the
bleacher report app presented by our
friends draftkings that's right my name
is connor rogers alongside the man the
myth the las vegas legend i am a fan of
that jacket greg what is good how are we
feeling my man
feeling good connor feeling generous
absolutely so generous in fact i want to
give out a hoodie man i i want to give
out a hoodie right
now i'm in the comments connor i am in
the comments
looking for takes looking for takes i
see a maxwell rexella in the in the
comments saying darren waller i see
britney baby also saying darren waller
uh
i see rype six saying your jets plus 14
connor fupa says obj is going over 14
yards everybody that i mentioned
everybody that i mentioned you are
walking away with the hoodie and welcome
to the squad ride that's right the
closer we get to christmas the more
generous you seem to get you guys know
the drill by now right every single week
we are looking for touchdown scores
who's getting in the end zone locks we
ask you on the app we ask you on social
these are the top picks of this week
naji harris at the top no big ben this
week they rely on naji as a workhorse
every single week it's only going to be
magnified this week against those lions
jt it's been an absolute beast in
october and november james connor aaron
jones mike evans that buck's offense is
pretty banged up so a lot of pressure
and a lot of targets from mike evans
stefan diggs looking to get right
against those jets porter patterson
having his career year which is crazy
jerry judy great to see him back on the
field and featured to get things started
here let's take a look at some of our
favorite lock legend videos from last
week that we didn't get to show you
we got six options i'm gonna roll one
die
[Music]
i'm betting on trayvon digg to get a
pick six against the broncos you know i
gotta lock up your boy jamar chase
anytime touchdown score
[Music]
the energy from the better is good right
now greg it's real good i know the
energy on your end is good as well what
are you giving away to the people today
connor i'm not only giving away hoodies
but i'm also giving away two not one but
two nfl jerseys today one goes to the
winning lock legend one goes to the
winning lock legend and one goes to a
lucky commenter like yourself so don't
go anywhere don't go anywhere get in the
comments and do what you guys do i need
gifts i need emojis but most importantly
i need winners only please all right
four legendary picks to show you you
know the deal by now the winner takes
off they take home the jersey they take
home the title of squad ride leader and
for us
for greg we got to raise those odds a
little bit maybe get some plus money
action trail them and get rich have some
fun let's not waste any time let's get
the show on the road the first pitch
comes from koozie k 33
tell us who's scoring a touchdown today
koozie k
come on leave your car come on come on
come on come on come on come on come
here it's fast it's fast it's fast
i have three nfl running backs that i
need to score a touchdown this weekend
see the colors right i need you to pick
one
i'll take the green
you picked aaron jones it's like a
packers
well it didn't seem like he wanted much
to do with that but he still made his
choice in aaron jones who if you've seen
these pictures rolling into lambeau
field today it's gonna be a snow game
which means it's gonna be a lot of work
on the ground and it's gonna be a lot of
fun i'm excited all right so aaron jones
on the board minus 115. we can get that
to plus money decision of the daytime
first challenger familiar face in w
trammell let's take a look
legend
vr nation we're here with a couple
anytime touchdown scores
let's let the box
[Applause]
stefan diggs lock it in the ball
w travel on that mini golf grind
bringing on stefan diggs is the choice
so we got two minus money here i like
both these options pretty exciting greg
how are you feeling right now we got the
water bottle legend we got the mini golf
legend which are you feeling
connor
let me hop into the comments let me
actually talking to the people
what i need you guys to do is get in the
comments and let us know let me know let
connor know should we ride with the
water bottle legend or should we ride
with the mini golf legend connor let's
dig into it aaron jones uh
we know aaron rodgers missed last week
so i think that they're slowly but
surely going to get him involved into
the offense this week what does that
mean connor that simply means they will
run the ball starting the game so
therefore i could see aaron jones
getting in the end zone today
but with that being said
the buffalo bills laid an egg last week
in jacksonville so you know they're
coming back with the vengeance
and my guy stefan diggs is josh allen's
favorite target i like that too uh but
you know what we can do here connor you
know what we can do that people know
what we can do we boost these odds up
but connor which way are you leaning
this is a tough one man i like the mini
golf video a lot i think that's a good
way to decide but i like the aaron jones
pick better and a lot of that is because
of the timing as soon as you and i sat
down to do the show today we saw that
snowy field getting ready to go and
looked at each other and said aaron
jones might have a big day especially
against seattle so i'm excited about
aaron jones are the people in the
comments feeling the same way are they
leaning staffon digs against that jet
secondary let me see connor handle the
diamonds right now i got
the handy dandy iphone is here connor
the handy dandy iphone is here i got
poppy jessie sandix shout out to you
probably jesse you were walking away
with honey i got trapped trey saying
aaron jones aaron jones shout out to you
traptrey you are walking away with a
hoodie i want to win i want to win says
fire fire fire emoji jones shout out to
you i want to win uh i got one more one
more in me connor i got one more emmy d
cafe seven d cafe seven says yes aaron
jones so shout out to ud cafe seven and
everybody that i mentioned you guys are
all walking away with the hoodie care uh
i think i think it's apparent brother i
think it is apparent we're we're riding
with the water bottle legend and aaron
jones moving on to the next round yeah
koozie k moving on with that aaron jones
pick there is no doubt about that it
seemed like the audience really liked
that one for round two
but it's redemption time it is the
redemption tour we got a revenge game
because the fetch legend atlas is back
this pitch is from n goldberg
and i think he's ready to get some
redemption let's see it let's see it
what's up bleacher report we are back
here with everybody's favorite betting
dog atlas and today he's here to redeem
himself last week wasn't the best pick
but today we're gonna throw both balls
and see which one he comes back with in
the blue ball we got naji harris and in
the green ball we've got jonathan taylor
for this week's anytime touchdown score
ready atlas
oh he had the blue ball but he's coming
back with a green ball
today he picked green ball jonathan
taylor anytime touchdown score against
the jaguars
atlas looking to make up for that l from
last week i like the jt pick a lot we
need a lock here that is what we need
greg can the water bottle legend keep
things moving or is atlas back on as the
squad ride leader potentially
connor let's find out but before we find
out i have to talk to people you guys
let us know
are we rocking with aaron jones are we
rocking with jonathan taylor
uh connor
we know jonathan taylor is the engine in
indianapolis he is the engine in
indianapolis he goes they go
when we talked about aaron jones playing
in the snow we talked about it
uh i'm actually torn here i'm actually
torn here we've been seeing jonathan
taylor break long runs break long uh
catches out of the backfield all season
can he do it again uh maybe i think so
but i also feel strong about aaron jones
scoring so you guys get in the comments
and let us know which way we chalene
connor which way are you leading i'm
going with the guy that scored every
week of october he scored every week of
november and i think that's gonna keep
things moving i think it's jt greg i
love what jonathan taylor is doing right
now for this colts offense he obviously
ran wild the last time we saw him on
thursday night football i think carson
wentz they really lean on that run game
to take away from any wence turnover so
i feel good about aaron jones there's no
doubt about that and you can see the
odds right there but if we can get jt to
plus money i am all in on that happening
i'll ride with atlas one more time
hey connor if we could get jt to plus
money that will be legendary but guess
what that's what we do
we are legendary here on the scribe
right but i'm in the comments connor i
am in the comments uh looking for takes
and i see i see noah goldberg noah's in
actually in the comments shout out to
you he's watching you're walking away
with a hoodie for being in the comments
he says atlas shout out to atlas uh here
we go i see shane shannon
mcguckin says jonathan taylor he has a
jonathan taylor give shout out to you
shannon mcguckin you were walking away
with a hoodie i also see
uh baby ap one seven zero says j t
at home shout out to you baby ap170
patriot 73 also says uh aaron jones he
says aaron jones for the value but right
below him ray beau 54 says jonathan
taylor
for today and i think that that's what
we're riding with connor we're just
going to call it we're going to call it
yeah it appears yeah it's over we're
just gonna go with jonathan taylor in
goldberg moving on to the next round
round two in the books jonathan taylor
moving on atlas the fetch legend moving
on still got round three though this
thing is far from over so far all right
next up young cauliflower what do you
got for us in round three can you take
down the fetch legends
hey can you lock the door real quick
yeah sure
queen arrow patterson is scoring a
touchdown against the cowboys this
weekend
oh yeah that's definitely locked the
door lock legend coming in with a
fantasy hero of this season so far and
cordaro patterson
and he's got a juicy matchup against
dallas today and he's got plus money
greg this is a little
this is a little dicey right here this
is gonna make the people think about
this one how are you feeling in our
final round
connor this one's this one is really
tricky this one's dicey this one's
interesting so this one's so interesting
in fact
i don't know which way i want to lean
connor but what i do know is i need you
guys at home to get in the comments and
let us know who's gonna win this thing
who who's the who's gonna be the squad
ride winner of the week is it cordell
patterson is it jonathan taylor
cordell patterson has been having a good
year conor he plays wide receiver he
plays running back i mean who thought
that he could be the engine in atlanta
but that's what he's turning out to be
the engine in atlanta uh
but he's facing that dallas team and
their defense is not that intimidating
so
i kind of like the cordell patterson
fake jonathan taylor's pick is more safe
and you guys know what we can do here we
boost odds all the time
connor which way are you leaning my
takeaway is that both these guys get in
the end zone this week you like
cordero's money a little bit more there
because it's plus money but if we can
get jt away from that minus 175 and
closer to plus 100 jump on that all day
i gotta have a disclaimer here i have a
cordaro patterson same game parlay today
for receiving yards for a touchdown so
i'm a little biased but i have no
problem backing atlas again let's let
the people decide our squad ride leader
for this week
connor i am in the comments i'm in the
handy dandy iphone and i see sage 7766
says patterson definitely she is rocking
with cornell patterson uh
young gravy 56 says taylor easy money
lock lock lock expert three says jt gets
a tv uh baby ap is back into the in the
comments he says dallas defense is
calm i'm pretty sure that means that
they're not uh intimidating or not a
good defense but uh i got one more in me
connor one more emmy
in davis 917 says gotta be taylor still
he is too
dangerous connor i think i think i want
to call it i think it's time she should
just call it
yeah we should just call it right there
the winner of this week's
squad ride is in goldberg in jonathan
taylor uh
yeah that's that's that's what we're
rocking with let me show you guys
something let's pull up the graphic so i
can show you guys what we can do here on
the squad ride you guys see jonathan
taylor sitting at -175
watch this magic oof
there it goes
money now
plus 100 it is now plus 100 counter uh
make sure you guys check out the vr
betting socials for our links for the
odds we'll send us your screenshots of
your bets send us your videos and your
celebrations
most importantly we want winners and
winners only please actually put that in
the comments i'm giving away hoodies
y'all fill the comments up with winners
only please connor let's get to the
community contest man man that's a good
one for us to get back on track plus
money jonathan taylor
feeling good about our squad ride leader
this week atlas revenge tour all right
you know what the deal is you heard greg
say community contest time we're looking
at the mid-season super bowl race right
now what we asked you in the br betting
community was if you had to place a
hundred dollars on someone to win the
super bowl this season you got a good
feel so far this year here are the
current odds leaders right now some of
our uh top dogs here tampa bay of course
with tom brady no surprise buffalo it's
been a roller coaster for them but
they've had some bright bright moments
in the afc the rams now with odell
beckham you saw arizona on that board
tennessee's been hot lately dallas with
dak back always going to be in the
picture and then kansas city with
mahomes we know what he can do but they
just don't look like themselves this
year so yeah with that being said we're
green bay no green bay on this board as
well
that's very fun yeah the browns
and it's wide open right now it's
completely wide open if buffalo didn't
lose the jacksonville last week you're
probably looking at them being the
leader on this board as well so all
right we got two of our favorite
comments greg let him know what's up
what i need you guys to do
is get in the comments and which of
these is the better take i'm giving away
a hoodie to whomever you guys choose so
let's take a look at the first comment
from it's hard wig
it's hardwick says
titans going all the way and still not
getting any respect free money money
always loaded up
king henry coming back in january and he
throwing everybody out the curb
connor
what is your take on this one i think
it's a little rich i think derek henry
is going to be back yeah he's going to
rehab like an absolute monster and he's
different i just it comes down to one
thing for me here greg besides the fact
that they lost in my new york jets which
gives me the ultimate fear can you
picture ryan tannehill hoisting that
lombardi trophy i i don't think this is
free money i like the boldness yeah i
like how hot they've been for weeks now
i'm just not there yet my man what about
you
yeah i don't know if that's free money
connor i don't know if that's free money
money for the buck
yeah
free money for the buck yeah it's just
hard for me uh
putting money on ryan tannehill to win a
championship but let's move on to the
next comment from polo0424
connor i say nfc team winning the ship
bucks rams packers there's no team in
the afc i have faith in winning it all
if the bills go another super bowl loss
for that franchise wow that is bold he's
just writing off the bills automatically
before the game is even set up or before
we even know if they're going to make it
this one's surprising connor what about
you yeah bold and ice cold here but i'm
i'm with it i'm looking at the nfc for a
super bowl winner i'm totally there with
you the box obviously is what everybody
would deem as the safest pick there's no
safe pick for a super bowl winner you're
not going to rule out green bay i like
that you brought them up greg not being
on the board there absolutely the
packers and the rams mcvay's been there
before and and you know he's still
hungry to actually get one we'll see
what odell does in that offense they
lost robert woods but they're still
going to be right and maybe they get cam
akers back for their backfield in the
playoffs they're hoping for that so i
like this comment a lot i think that
it's going to be an nfc super bowl year
yeah i mean
i like the packers i also like the bills
but nfc does have the stronger division
uh i'm in the comments i am in the
comments
reading
and looking
for takes i say
i see sir easy says watch the chiefs
make a turnaround and everyone eat pro
chiefs kingdom shout out to you sir easy
you are walking away with a hoodie uh
let me see i think
lonnie lonnie hawkman is in the comments
saying i really think the raiders will
come back and win the west and the super
bowl wow that wow
that is really really bold and uh i
don't see that one happening but you are
still walking away with hoodie uh connor
i'm gonna call this one i'm i'm gonna
call this one
i like
polo0424's take uh on the nfc winning
the ship so i'm gonna give polo0424
a hoodie for being the winner of the
comments contest so shout out to you
palo 0424 you were walking away with a
bleacher report hoodie i like it all
right before we get to our boldest bets
because i know you're all dying for
those we got something new for you this
week we got prop lock
or drop it and we are looking at one
game we are looking at the player props
from one game focusing on that snowy
lambeau field with green bay and seattle
aaron rodgers is back russell wilson is
back and man i'm excited about this greg
because you know you and i love those
props so tell the people what's going on
definitely love those props i need
everybody to
get the comments and tell me if these
props are a lock or if we need to
immediately
drop them i'm giving away hoodies to
whoever can help us out but most
importantly you guys already know what
we need we need winners only please all
right let's check out the prop connor
starting it off for us is russell wilson
to throw over or under 247.5
passing yards this is russ's first game
back since the finger injury and surgery
on his throwing hand he missed three
games honor
will he be able to get the seahawks
offense going
again
i do
not think so i don't think that he's
going to hit this over on his passing
yard simply because we know what it is
that what the weather is like in green
bay connor we know what the weather is
like in green bay russ coming off of
injury i don't know if i'm going to put
my money on the over connor what do you
think yeah i'm afraid of this one right
and he did this the first three weeks of
the season with these he went over this
marker and had no problem with that the
problem here is greg you nailed it the
weather is an issue number two this is
out of his hands for the most part when
you look at the top quarterbacks in the
league whether it's allen whether it's
mahomes those kind of guys stafford
they're dropping back 40 plus times a
game for the most part for russ he's in
between 23 to 32 pass attempts that's
not a lot and this number while it's not
that high you've got the conditions
against you you've got your own
offensive game plan against you and
you're coming back from injury so
this is a prop i traditionally would
stay away from because of the unknown of
the weather the injury but i actually
like the under because seattle's game
plan is run run run run week after week
yes sir they love to pound the ball in
seattle and look connor if you look at
the comments everybody is really riding
with both of us uh i got matt dodgers in
the comments says snowing right the
under shout out to you matt dodger
you're walking away with the hoodie
d-boy 22 says russ gets 50-plus rushing
yards though i believe he said
under on the passing totals but he says
50 plus rushing yards shout out to you
d-boy 22 you are walking away with it i
got one more in me uh connor i got one
more in me uh
i got vanari benari says under under
under shout out to you bernardi shout
out to everybody that i mentioned you
are all walking away with a hoodie all
right connor let's move on to our next
prop
aaron
jones the guy we talked about him
earlier we're looking at his rush yards
connor is he going to go over or under
60 and a half
aaron jones hasn't hadn't had a run for
more than 20 yards over the past three
games the packers are rotating aj dillon
in the backfield now more frequently
connor so he's taking some snaps away
from jones
will having aaron rodgers back get jones
back on track i think it will i yeah yes
yeah go ahead greg i think yes conor i
think yes i think it will because they
have to get aaron rodgers back into the
floor things he took last week off so
how do you do that connor you run the
ball you run the ball do you run a
little
action off the run and then you open up
the offense so i do see uh aaron jones
getting the rock today uh
i'm gonna go over 60 and a half what
about you connor which way are you
lean i am too and that might surprise a
lot of people he's only done this four
out of their nine games this year gotten
over this marker so he's not somebody
that traditionally rushes for insanely
high totals he's more of all-purpose
yards right receiving yards combined
with those rushing yards and getting in
the end zone but why i like the over
like you said the conditions they got to
run the ball yes he splits time with aj
dillon but aaron rodgers coming back i
don't think this is a game where he's
dropping back and throwing over and over
again and i do think this is finally
that week aaron jones can break off one
of those big runs that supplements the
yardage total as well so traditionally
when you look at this on paper it
screams stay away this is not a reliable
prop bet but overall because of the
situation i actually like this one a lot
i'll go with the over
connor it appears the people in the
comments are riding it with us as well i
got d cafe seven says big night for
jones shout out to you d cafe you were
walking away with hoodie h smith
smith125 says over over over shout out
to you h smith you're walking away with
a hoodie uh one more one more logan lee
logan l3 iggs says over lock it in
uh hey the people are riding connor the
people are riding with us they're riding
with aaron jones over shout out to
everybody i said you guys are all
walking away with the hoodie all right
bonus bets of the week the best time of
the week greg let's get into it we need
the people involved in this one because
i know you still got another big
giveaway and you and i are looking to
make some money so let's not waste any
time
yes yes what i need you guys to do is
get in the comments and give us a bold
bag give us a long shot it was your
longest long shot uh it could be a
parlay it could be anything we just want
long shots in the comments also tell me
if you're riding with me or if you're
riding with connor's
vote his bet
but connor
let's get right to it man let's get
right to it what do you got as your boat
is bet this week getting back in the par
leg here greg staying away from the two
touchdowns for once getting back into
the parlay here touchdown scores three
leg i like
the teams that these guys are playing
josh allen against the jets naji harris
without his quarterback big ben against
the lions jonathan taylor our squad ride
leader against jacksonville these guys
are reliable on the ground
and week after week pretty much and with
the three-legged parlay on draftkings
got a little profit booster there so
this is over plus 500 the three-legged
parlay for the one o'clock slate i'm
feeling good greg what do you got here
connor uh
i want to talk about the cowboys last
week they laid an egg
last week against the broncos but uh
guess what connor they're playing again
today they're playing again today and i
think that they're gonna have to get
their offense going they're gonna have
to get their offense going
and how do you do that you play physical
and you run the ball
so with that being said i got my boy
ezekiel elliott taking on that atlanta
falcons defense they're not intimidating
zeke
go get two go get the offense flowing
coach feed zeke feed him and uh let's go
get two touchdowns man it's sitting that
plus 310 i like it i like it get the
offense going run the ball feed zeke
it's simple let's go yeah and all their
wide receivers have been nursing
injuries they got to get back to what
works what was the origin of this
offense and that's ezekiel elliott
behind that offensive line running
running running help dak out so i like
that greg i'm feeling good about it
gotta know two things i need to know who
are the people riding with my ridiculous
parlay or you're uh you're all online on
zeke
and you still have a jersey to give away
to the comment section
yes sir okay look it i see a whole bunch
of takes in the comments i'm loving the
long shots i got isaac boatman and sorry
connor this one oh no no no actually
this is not what i did this is he's
going with jonathan taylor two
touchdowns plus
indianapolis spread let's go with
jonathan taylor two touchdown plus
indianapolis spread isaac boatman that
deserves a jersey that deserves the
jersey love the take
love the two you're jt jersey on
yeah yeah bye
take take this jersey money and go get a
jt jersey uh i see expert recess jarrett
golf three tds and a lion win wow those
odds have to be
i have to be insane astronauts have
those odds have to be insane uh cowboy
bounce back zeke scores two touchdowns
shout out to you cleo shout out to
everybody that commented shout out to
everybody in the comments shout out to
everybody watching man uh connor you you
might want to start talking before i
start giving away more hoodies brother
i'm just saying john
christmas is coming up yeah we got a lot
going on going keep going
i got one more of me then connor dante
divincienzo says lions moneyline shenzo
moneyline
he's building some money he's reacting
to that big ben news i like they need a
win they need a win they play hard for
their coach i'm not gonna make fun of it
i'm i'm scared of it i got their spread
when it opened but i'm not uh we'll see
yeah we'll see greg i don't know but i
like everybody's getting on the boldest
bets train it's not just you and i
sitting up here throwing out plus 300
plus 500 odds for fun everybody's got
their own mayhem
good luck with your wagers everyone this
was a blast i feel like the comments
really brought it today congrats all our
hoodie and jersey winners if you uh
don't hear from someone right away you
will within 24 hours br betting is going
to dm you and take care of you thank you
to our lock legends koozie k the water
bottle legend w trammell the mini golf
legend and goldberg back with atlas the
squad ride leader hopefully he gets back
on the board this week and young
cauliflower the door lock legend enjoy
your football sunday everybody drop your
real-time takes in the sports betting
community stream in the br app and
follow us on ig stories all day
alongside the man in the nice jacket
greg ivory i'm connor rogers see you
next time same place same time
yes
[Music]
you